Hey everyone, Laci Green here!
Several of you recommended the documentary
"Miss Representation" for our next screening
room....so I watched it!....again.
It's been a few years so it's good to have
a refresher.
Miss Rep is available on Netflix, which is
my favorite go-to for movies and TV online.
If you don't have netflix, you're missing
out buddy.
Try it out free for a month at Netflix.com/DNews!
For those of you unfamiliar with the documentary,
it's a pretty compelling investigation of
gender representation in media.
The premise for the film is that our primary
source of information is the media and that
it has a very strong (often subconscious)
effect on us -- for better or worse.
You don't need to be some fancy scholar to
flip on the TV and realize that women are
often reduced to degrading, 1-dimensional
stereotypes -- that our bodies are valued
much more than our minds.
And, you probably don't even need to be a
woman yourself to realize those messages have
real effects on peoples' lives.
The film talks about consequences like eating
disorders, increased challenges for women
in politics and leadership, extreme under-representation
of women in literally every influential field,
the destructive female rivalry it creates,
and....violence against women.
How all of those things connect is laid out
pretty well.
The studies they call upon are a wake up call:
women hold 5% of clout positions in the mainstream
media, they make up 9% of movie directors
and 15% of film writers.
And, most visibly, a measly 18% of Congress.
Women make up over half of this country - 51%.
The stories behind these figures is a compelling
one.
That said, I'm not sure Miss Rep tells the
entire story.
A big part of it, sure.
I found some of the solutions to be condescending,
like Katie Couric telling women not to worry
about their weight and use their minds instead.
Many women KNOW they shouldn't worry about
their weight, but here we are.
It's an oversimplified diagnosis and solution.
Another part of the film that was ironic to
me was that the documentary ITSELF lacked
representation.
Women with disabilities, queer women - completely
missing.
Rachel Maddow was in the film and never addressed
how being out affects the vitriol she receives
about her show.
I'm not the type that thinks a film needs
to be EVERYTHING to EVERYONE -- of course
not.
But if we're talking about the portrayals
of WOMEN, as a group, the voices of women
who aren't straight, middle class, and white
should be included as well.
But hey, I guess they'll learn that in gender
studies 102.
This film is very much a 101, and I think
that's great.
A good thing to show people as an intro to
say "Hey, this is a big part of what this
massive field of research and activism is
all about".
So grab a friend and pull it up on Netflix.
It'll definitely get a good conversation started.
If you don't have Netflix, you can watch the
documentary for free at netflix.com/dnews.
If you've seen it, let me know what you think!
I'll see you next time!